just casually browsing YouTube nothing
surprised me anymore there's nothing new
nothing interesting wait a minute videos
for kids 5 little peopie jumping out of
bed no no
oh god no stop
to react to review this channel I need
help I need a meme expert who do I call
calling Ethan calling Vincent Bradbury
eat them from a tree a tree calling them
some h3h3
yeah I did what up and yeah somewhat
summoned me what's going on here
I found this channel it is too weird
it's the weirdest thing I have ever seen
I've definitely seen some weird stuff I
think that I'm probably up for the job
why don't you give me a look and then
let me get my initial reaction here I
don't think you're ready for this but
okay are you are you I mean I flipped it
I've seen some the weirdest stuff out
there this cannot possibly shock me
Miley come on zombie hole-in-one Phillip
and bumpy Ted what the [ __ ] is this dude
that shocked me dude I can't watch
anymore
I can't watch alright well that's it
that's it for us this is this up thank
you mean dissection um thank you so much
for coming I appreciate your help on the
meme experts this is just the tip of the
iceberg jumping on the bed
these got the jumping beautiful has a
very nice form on the top like I like
how it says rap in the title no yeah
dude this is some gangster [ __ ] this is
some [ __ ] rice come shake dude made
in production with rice gum rice comes
hottest new hit 5 a little PewDiePie
jumping on the bed why are they calling
me a monkey rude but I've heard a lot of
new hip-hop this year in 2015
kendrick lamar's come out some really
great tunes this is probably the best
rap song i've heard all year that's why
i wanted to show it to you because I
know you love and appreciate gangster
rap that's not even a meme that's just
good music if I'm being honest you they
have my actual shirt oh yeah dude they
did research they figured this out this
wasn't something they just put together
you can tell there's way more are you
seeing this oh my god you're taking on
Hitler at the I don't punch me right in
the throat
what is what the sound effects this
guy's just in his face promise me it
sounds like me why does Hitler sound
like me - I beat Hitler though I beat
Hitler everyone just sucks
World War two is done dude thank you
learning colors before I didn't read the
title learning colors with farting
PewDiePie what you wish you could dance
like that you wish you had those moves
like that Oh God
green toxic poop farts what would you
say if you walked in on your kid
watching that I I would part of me would
be disappointed but then I just realized
it'd be equally words if you watch a
PewDiePie video ouch
shots fired at yourself that's the first
time come on it would be the same thing
if they like if you had a kid and they
would watch your channel you'd be like
what the [ __ ] are you doing so no guess
I found this channel through these
farting PewDiePie PewDiePie Nursery
Rhymes
but little did I know so this channel
was made in 2011 oh wow
they're classic they're old-school but
their first video is uploaded 2015 oh I
smell a conspiracy they've been sitting
on that property
no they bought the channel whoa was it
something before I think so why the [ __ ]
would they name have a channel called
toys in Japan and name it sudoko
interesting can we think can we look
that up somehow I don't know but I can
we super sleuth that [ __ ]
let me wanna there is something going on
here I run the memes and I'm gonna do
some research for you right now dude I'm
on this mainframe and I didn't find
anything I didn't find any answers for
you they're making Bank on uploading
these and if you look at their channel
literally they uploaded another P 2 pi 1
guerilla vs. PewDiePie 5 see that
gorilla verse feet by superhero battle
fingers
they literally upload 7 videos a day the
fact that this guy can make 5 hour long
videos a day yeah it is Kree
me it is weird what is going on in this
guy's grandma's basement there's a sweat
shop of Pixar rejects Shh
misters evil Indian twin brother is in
the basement
working on the Senate that son of a
[ __ ] I knew it all along
I can't tell if they're trying to be
weird or if they just are weird or if
they are trying too hard to be weird you
know what I mean
that's a really interesting question and
I have to say that this is just this guy
thinks in my opinion that this is very
normal
honestly there's there's definitely a
metaphor here because Trump is riding
with like a huge dick with a syringe tip
dick
so he's like that's like a metaphor for
power and nil uh oh my god what is
happening I'm beating the [ __ ] out of a
cat
oh god that cat is like freaky looks
like he just had a load in his pants Oh
what the [ __ ] is this
but the [ __ ] is this why am i singing
all the sudden I want to see my gosh
you can't
they're finger mommy finger where are
you
Here I am Here I am how do you do Oh
keeping no anything come back to me hey
let yourself feel it you got a war
before you put on little black babies
like that I'm so sorry I didn't know you
can't just pop that on you better give
me a truther warning something man I
need a hold on a break
how was I supposed to know what the [ __ ]
was that you never know what you're
gonna get in toys in Japan that's the
thrill it's like a riot this is my new
favorite channel I started this off
thinking it would be something horrific
but I mentioned this content dude seen
Hulk we'd like to get a graph of that
huge syringe I'm into it nothing's
hotter than sing Hulk skull [ __ ] Mickey
with a syringe can we show this I don't
know I don't even know how to describe
what I'm looking at without like [ __ ]
up what if this was actually what's
happening on the moon like how do we
know this isn't what's happening on the
moon right now and there's no evidence
the thing though is that even if I
studied to animate I could probably not
pull this [ __ ] up yeah this is this is a
lot of talent this is something special
I don't know how I'm gonna sleep at
night dude like I appreciate you coming
out here like I see it's a big project
you asked me for help that's me I'm I
feel this is damaged me permanently
can I ask by the way how did Hitler make
his way into a children show like I'm
all the things they had to choose from
in the world
they chose Hitler this says videos for
kids let's watch it five Lola Kim
Kardashian dish what's with the nursery
rhymes
that's funny oh my god oh my god
Felix I need a minute just to watch this
by myself now that is some good [ __ ]
what the hell am i lucky yeah it looks
like he doesn't have skin on we are how
is this for kids it's a dinosaur with a
pacifier versus a giant dog it's
basically a mint oh it's part what the
hell stop stop stop okay okay okay what
the [ __ ] yes so this is the original
monkey jumping on the bed no bad this
will check when it did it oh my god no a
black mama I don't see what's confusing
about this it's just straight up content
Oh
I can't imagine any kid watching this
and not just like crying their eyes out
alright so that was react to toys in
Japan or Nursery Rhyme videos with each
Ethan from h3h3 check out his channel if
you want more do you do react videos
anymore not really but I mean you know
we've got stuff we talk about stuff we
look at stuff well check out a pen and
link in description thank you so much
for watching leave a like if you enjoyed
and as always stay awesome press if you
want to make it on YouTube these days
just make long ass videos [ __ ] any type
of pacing quality and none of that [ __ ]
that
get up get the [ __ ] out quality I told
you I totally I want you get I never had
to say that you want to make it on
YouTube these day you got to have watch
time and if you don't have a watch time
is it's basically you just got to make
long ass [ __ ] videos